well brian as students get back into the
classroom ccsd is rolling out his plans
for spring sports
sports director chris matthews joining
us now in the studio with the plan for
clark county and also reaction chris
well thank you denisia with the governor
giving the thumbs up and superintendent
dr jesus jara's
contact sports will soon be back at your
favorite ccsd campus
here's the plan now spring sports
practices begin in early april for a
variety of boys and girls sports
with competition beginning april 16th
for the intramural fall sports that had
to be adjusted because of covet
football will be back but not with games
but full contact competition
within each school basically a spring
football practice to get ready for the
2021 season
other fall intramural sports may take
place in may
both boys and girls they've staggered
the sports so that students aren't
forced to choose a single sport and of
course
no fans allowed coaches and other adults
will have to test
negative before all activities